[Music]
paul is with us in sacramento hey paul
how are you
i'm walking on to the break of dawn hey
yo what's up paul i stole that from you
oh my a dr john fan okay
what's up all right all right so
i'm gonna give you my whole life and
financial picture i'm 19 years old
i'm planning on getting married in the
next two years and then i would want to
rent for two years after that
so i'm looking to buy a house in
probably four to five years from now
i have forty thousand dollars in cash
right now
and i'm thinking of putting that in an s
p 500
until i'm ready to buy a house and just
keep adding to that
but my mom says that
i should probably that i should hold
that as cash
in case a good deal comes up or
something like that just
to have that cash ready on me on hand
because i'm going to be going through a
lot of changes
so you can get it out of an s p 500 in
20 minutes
yeah it's as liquid as your savings
account is as far as getting a hold of
it the downside is the stock market
might be down that day or that week or
that month
and so i mean if forty thousand dollars
if it had a ten percent drop in the
stock market that would be an unusually
bad year
statistically unusually bad year
and that would have cost you four
thousand dollars if the stock market is
up
ten fifteen percent you're going to make
four
five six thousand dollars
per year doing this so if you can handle
emotionally the swing of you may make
four or five or six and you might lose
four that's probably your over and under
on the thing then the s p 500 is okay if
you can handle all of that
right the chances of it of your 40
turning into 20 is
very very very low
it's only happened a couple of times in
history
the chances of your 40 turning into 80
in one year
never
happened it's never happened
right
so you know so you're over and under is
what you're looking at you know what's
your best case scenario worst case
scenario and can you emotionally handle
the swing between those two
numbers
so john from a
psychology situation phd in psychology
you're in counseling
i was reading a study i don't know if
you've ever seen this data or not that
when someone loses money on an
investment you have seen it like that
you're smiling when they when you lose
money on an investment if for every
dollar that you lose on an investment
to feel the same way
uh
emotionally you have to gain three
dollars
losses impact our emotions at a three to
one ratio
heavier
than gains
lift us emotionally yes i don't remember
the exact teeter-totter there but i know
daniel kahneman's just he's he changed
the world with his studies on that but
this idea and i never thought of this
dave i'm so
obsessed with losses that i don't think
about
non-future earnings right so we get so
obsessed with
yeah well and the reason is is that
you've experienced probably you may have
a scar
where you say okay i lost that money and
you know i i but you know the stock
market like people uh here's an example
okay when in 2008 when the market
dropped from 13 000 to 6400 dropped
basically in half
the dow did
we had people and people will tell you
to this day that they lost all
of their retirement
in the 2008 downturn
well mathematically that's completely
impossible it's inaccurate right it's
completely impossible that you lost all
of your retirement if it was in mutual
funds
you lost half of it
if you happen to buy
at the very top and you happen to be the
most unlucky person in the world when
you chose to sell at the exact bottom
you would have lost half of your money
um
and by the way it's not at 6 500 today
it's close to you know north of what 30
000 today so 40 000. so
um you know that the dow jones
industrial average in other words so
that you know market is up 5x from the
bottom there but in that effort to lose
you know
to emotionally recover from that
downturn you completely avoided the
market since 2008 you've you've missed
that your million dollars would have
been five or six million right or we see
this especially missed out on when you
put five thousand dollars or twenty
thousand or a hundred thousand dollars
or a million into your company and your
company's not doing well
we're so loss adverse that we keep
dumping money into that thing instead of
cutting our losses and moving yeah it's
very difficult especially when it's a
small business person who their dreams
or identity are tied up that's right
yeah you just do it with marriages too
we just keep going and we don't stop and
have conversations yeah we say uh
necessary endings yeah our buddy henry
cloud right